good morning good morning good morning
good morning believe nation it's awesome
to be back happy Monday it's time for
gratitude journal I've street number 26
we do this every weekday showing our
gratitude showing our love I think it's
important for entrepreneurs to be
equally unsatisfied with the world and
what they want to go and create but also
super grip for what they have and
happier healthier more productive
entrepreneurs will make this world a
better place that's what I believe at
least uh what two things we do
consistently it's every weekday it's not
just once a week or once a month you got
to show gratitude daily for it to impact
you and you have to actually feel it so
when your listing things off and you
come up with your list of three things
just take a couple seconds to think
about why it's important to you I don't
have my baseball hat on I left it in the
car I'm a blue jay day today so go jays
go later on tonight we'll see hopefully
they can pull out a win so I'm going to
show through things I'm good for today
you guys leave it in the live chat where
your great before and for those you
watching after leave it down in the
comments don't be a lurker don't just
watch but I want you to feel the
benefits you know do with me so I'm
going to start off um number one is easy
i'm doing my audio book today right
after this again I gotta run from this
get in the car drive to get to record my
audio book they too so pumped um so no
league of legends live stream after this
are you guys I last last time we did it
you so should get about 80 pages they
consider 80 pages a good day in audio
book world and we did 120 so super
pumped about that and have today and I
think next week one more to finish off
I'm so excited guys I'm so excited I'm
so excited I can't wait to go um but I
got you this first I got to be with you
guys until nine ten
um that's the first thing number two I
had a really great meeting last night
with one of my up-and-coming salsa
instructors not an instructor yet he's
an assistant and trying to kind of learn
and get to next up become an instructor
for us and we had a good discussion
around his one word and what that means
to him and digging in and he's realizing
that you know he wants to live he wants
to get his he has a message he found his
message he finally found his message and
he wants to start living the message and
then figuring out you know the three
things that are most important to him
and when you go through the exercises
part of your credo you often realize
that one of them at least usually you're
not doing enough of you should be doing
it but you're not usually cause you're
afraid you're afraid of how other people
might react or judge you or whatever and
so it's his glaring bright light on
yourself realizing that you know what I
just haven't done it because I'm afraid
and so is it was a really good growth
moment last night that I'm super
grateful for and I'm so pumped to see
where he's going to take all this stuff
number three sits around the one word
theme i'm recording the one word
audiobook last night he had his one word
i'll be grateful for my one word you
know believe is made such a huge impact
on my life I've always been about
believe but what I really articulated it
first to myself and then to the world
that's when I really started to see the
business take off instead of with my
newsletter the first newsletter that i
wrote around with a belief theme i had
twice the engagement as the other ones
in my sister wrote to me and she said I
really like your newsletters now
actually reading it it's a good Stuckart
then I made a video about believe and we
you know my previous video took a year
my best video had a hundred thousand
views in one year and the believe video
got a hundred thousand
in one month and these are like little
small tests as an appeal this is working
I started applying with everything my
whole business my youtube channel even
my life I've built now around believe
and I've seen just huge growth and so
I'm super grateful for that so that's
what those are my three great before
audiobook day today round to give him
for the meeting last night and good for
me finding my one word we have five
minutes and then I'm out so let's get to
the live chat and see what you guys are
grateful for I start off with my oval
novel got a right Melville hey believe
nation when you get before today he led
us off he's good for my family friends
and co-workers for hashtag improving
myself every day i love that j rise in
the house deco for warm welcoming
inviting cafes important i got a lot of
work done in cafes Thank of her inspired
impactful game-changing high leverage I
ideas and execution of that thank you
for clients food and all of nature
that's good my bill is also grateful for
Jay rises spying cameras yeah on Friday
Jay came over I have a spy cam set up in
my office and caught me dancing to some
reggae and we decided to post out on the
channel says that's a fun weekend video
the check out if you haven't yet cup
Rishi cup TV hashtag couple of everyone
welcome aboard zeno great before number
one for disney for creating probably the
most sorry for creating probably the
majority of my childhood movies I love
Disney we go every year I take caden
Nina every year to Disney World such a
huge blast we got to start planning at
March scary that we're ready plan me
from our trip kind of do it number two
clouds for making our view of the sky
less repetitive and more beautiful I'd
like that I really like that 3 j rizal
Wow j rizal jer eyes getting the new
nickname j RZA for capturing an awesome
day session with this spy cam Jay rises
again a lot of gratitude in this from
here
today what else we have up it just
skipped again god I love YouTube
comments okay where we where we were
Adrian good morning cold morning
everyone best your probe good morning
everyone I love it I love it I love it
what else what else what else best you
Pro while lots of people here that's
right this gratitude journal time best
you Pro let's show up I love it cold
blast hashtag beast mode I know rock aye
sir Tim's in the house all right I love
it que el bien bit before number one
Jason for providing me the opportunity
to help a haitian immigrant via phone
all the way from Arizona well I'm in
Dominican Republic very cool i like that
caddy to false am i hope and i said ok
hello welcome aboard Rishi Evan your
voice sounds strong happy for you I'm
almost there I burned my voice out it
was two weeks ago and I haven't stopped
talking so on the weekend I tried to not
talk to too much we went to a big party
I hosted a party on Friday night for my
salsa helpers Friday night Saturday
night Saturday night it was a boat
cruise and then like you're yelling
about the boat and the music and so
yesterday like okay I gotta gotta rest I
gotta rest a voice so I'm almost there
I'm gonna bring it though I'm so pumped
I'm so pumped Nick Nick cute Nick you
nkiru nikki rio and i said okay hi
family welcome aboard Adrian people from
Monday I love it people from Monday
that's right laptops & music what else
Reza hi Evan what's up Reza colt how
does it how does it do it every day like
this I can do it every day I can do it
but every day is hard you just built the
routine you built the habits join us
start your week day every day with us
we'll get you fired up ready to go what
else what else what else
I'm a big fan welcome aboard sky's the
limit all nine great rising everyone
like that intro great rise in everyone
I'm give afore obstacles that require
creative solutions grateful for
obstacles skies the limits on fire today
I love this people that helped me grow
and health I love it resident your
videos are nice much appreciated Tim I'm
grateful for this cool live video with
Evan and hashtag believe nation I'm good
for my husband 29th anniversary today I
love that cam clap that up guys that's
awesome 29 years wow I thinking for six
beautiful children we've had together I
love that klb any I'm grateful for my
dog Chloe because she loves going to the
beach I love that I'd leave hey Evan
what's up Donna group of four life
itself I love that what else what else
what else sky's the limit all nine
people for you Evan and a belief nation
I agree and last one we should come to
be grateful for books of find me I
always find the right book at that time
I'll ever thank you guys nine ten hope
you have an amazing day today again no
league of legends live stream I am off
to go record my book and sorry I am late
and I need to run so have an amazing day
have an awesome start to the week go and
crush it do something that you're
passionate about today continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
i will see you soon